so the age of pleasure is bringing in a
whole new era of Janelle Monae so how
can you describe this era of your life
and your career
oh I'm in such a great like amazing
um space I've tapped more and more you
know into my freedom and
really how I'm living my life always
seeps into my art and not the other way
around so what you're hearing sonically
and and and you know is just a
reflection of um of where I am and I I
think that
um I'm more present
um I feel you know even even more safe
to
[Music]
um
you know explore
musically you know being non-binary I
think has really like freed my mind up
uh and sort of opened up my mind uh I
don't know I I yeah I just I've opened
up my
mind musically
um
and
just personally uh in such a new way and
I cannot wait for people to be able to
experience that June 9th when the age of
pleasure comes out yeah it's June 9th
what what message is it that you want
your your fans your listeners to get
from this album coming out next week
well my hope is that they can feel you
know there's a quote by Maurice White
from Earth Wind and Fire and and one of
my favorite songs all about love and he
would say if there ain't no Beauty make
some beauty and so this was my attempt
at making Beauty and capturing the
beauty around me
um I would host parties with my friends
like this album was made for my friends
by my friends with my friends
and my friends are from all over the
world from the continent South Africa
Canada Nigeria
um Jamaica uh Ghana the Caribbeans
Atlanta L.A like we would all gather and
we would create this safe space
um for each other to explore to just be
you know free of police free of judgment
and
what I said is I wanted to create music
that we loved a soundtrack to our
lifestyle and so my hope is that you can
feel what it's like to be with me and
around me with my friends and that you
will share that with your friends and
your loved ones and you'll create safe
spaces
um for yourselves and and this will be
the soundtrack for it
well it seems like your new music now
has this incredible
aspect of being unapologetically
yourself have you always exuded this
type of confidence or did it take you a
while to get to this place in your life
where you can be confident in your own
skin and share that with the world
it's always a journey you know just when
I thought I'm confident I'm free it's
like actually there's even more you know
levels to that and I think what you're
saying is me reaching different levels
yeah
so I uh just obviously I've been
listening to lipstick lover I watched
the video and everything there's so much
queer joy in that video in that video
how does it feel to make music that's so
authentically you and really represents
you as a person
it feels good you know you know I I
co-directed lipstick lover so for
something to come from me you know that
I I was like yes this this this is this
feels right you know there's everything
is authentic uh from the music to how
I'm living my life it's just great and I
know I can stand behind it it feels good
when you can just stand in front of to
the side behind it knowing that this is
me and the folks that you know
um get it and love it it feels good to
be celebrated and how I think about
myself is so powerful how we think about
ourselves uh is is super key even in the
midst of you know compliments or uh
criticism you know when I go back and I
sit with me I'm good I'm good
yeah and I and I'd be remiss if we
didn't talk about that I was scrolling
through Twitter and I saw the video you
posted of your mom when you uh showed
her the video of lipstick lover
um she said that she you know she needed
a little bit more male booty she said uh
her prediction was that it was gonna go
triple golden I don't know if it's gone
triple golden yet but how important has
your mom's support been to your success
no it's everything like I really don't
um
you know seek approval about my life you
know
um but it feels good when your mom
supports you it really does it really
feels good you know because she has her
life I have mine and for us to be able
to meet each other on these Journeys her
to respect me has been non-binary being
pansexual like for her to just in her
own way you know
um accept me means the world you know
she she brought me into this world and
she I've always as as a mom sort of I
guess sought out her approval so it
feels good to to have that yeah and my
dad called me too hey there you go he
was super supportive too so okay well
that's good like I'm good
yeah yeah it's definitely beautiful to
see especially for uh people out there
who may feel not so confident in
themselves you know to come out and to
really be who they are especially now
being pride month it's like people feel
that pressure right so yeah how does it
feel to how does it feel to use your
platform and create this inclusive art
where someone's gonna look at you and
look at your music and listen to it and
feel seen in their own body yeah I mean
I think that I do want to speak to that
because there wasn't uh there was a time
where my mind took my mom a while to
come around to accepting me being queer
you know and that was a tough time so I
just want you to know if you're watching
right now I feel you I see you I have
been you when I haven't felt supported
you know even still there may be family
members in my family who don't support
me in that way you know they may smile
and ask for tickets at the concert but
deep down they may have take issue with
my authenticity
um but I want you to know that you can
have children family I love you I love
you I love you Just the Way You Are
that's awesome thank you thank you for
that that's going to be a that's gonna
be a very beautiful clip and we're gonna
we're gonna be posting that for sure
because people need to hear it sometimes
you know they're not hearing from the
people they love so hearing it for
someone like you and hearing that
someone has been through hardships it's
uh it's really nice to relate to
something like that yeah um yeah I do I
do want to uh turn the table a little
bit here your single float was used in
NBA Saturday's Prime Time campaign are
you a big basketball fan I'm a huge
basketball fan so I gotta ask are you an
NBA fan you know listen
Michael Jordan I'm sorry was my favorite
player of all time uh I love basketball
and I'm an MVP basketball player so okay
as you saw me during All-Star game I
don't know if you got a chance to check
me out oh I did I did I did I wore these
exact shades
I was giving Babs Bunny
and I had the time of my life even
though some of the players thought it
was a good idea to slap my ball down I
still prevailed and our team
was you know for That season float was
the The Anthem like it was just perfect
I always imagined
um basketball players going into their
locker room listening to flow right
before it was time for them to go out
because that is a song to me that is a
soundtrack for Champions it's like when
you're going through you know your
metamorphosis or your Evolution that's
the song you put on to Hype you up and
to tell you to keep going forward
yeah so so let's go one to ten how would
you rate your basketball skills because
I played five years of college
basketball so like if we were to go
one-on-one where are you stacking up
like let's be honest you can't you can't
see me you cannot beat me even though
you were on a team you know and and you
were professional or you know you you
you you played for uh uh you play for a
team
I come and I bring something that only I
can bring you know you know that's
that's swag so I would kill you on that
you might score more points
but I'm gonna come in my outfit in my
look I'm gonna have a good time
I'm going to show that you can have so
much fun you have to take yourself so
seriously
I like it and because you practice so
much and you're probably really really
good you're gonna probably be so serious
and I'm gonna be like
you'll be free living you'll be free
yeah okay
um speaking of all this stuff that
you've been doing it's been almost a
decade you've had four studio albums
what would the Janelle Monae that used
to work at Office Depot think about all
the success that you've amounted to
today oh they would be so freaking
amazed but not like shocked but just
amazed and wow by it because that
Janelle Monae was poor was grinding
still had that same Spirit you know of
of bringing something new bringing
something bringing some Freedom
um never wanting to be boxed in never
letting anybody else Define them
um a lot you know a lot has changed you
know during that time I was just
realizing that I was queer now I'm fully
walking in it I'm non-binary
um I'm black I'm wild I'm I'm free I
feel safe in my body I feel like I have
a safe space to express myself whereas
probably in the past I didn't
um man I think they will be so proud
yeah I mean I I would be proud I mean
again and not not to mention all the
music you have of your acting career
which is yeah amazing people people were
obsessed with right there yeah people
were obsessed people were obsessed with
you and Daniel Craig on the Glass Onion
would you ever return to do another
Knives Out mystery I would be honored
but Ryan is not gonna cast if you've
already done the knives out with the
exception of Daniel Craig because he has
to be the detective Benoit Blanc that
comes in he's not casting but maybe I'll
get plastic surgery and I'll just become
a new actor and then I'll audition and
then I'll get it that's my goal
and I love those murder mysteries yeah I
know we yeah we know you do manifest the
best all right this is all the time I
have it's been an absolute pleasure to
know thank you so much uh looking
forward to the album next week and enjoy
your weekend six nine everybody I love
you Canada looking forward to coming on
tour there as well
peace